welcome to this video pop while 29 I
have played him a lot and I want a lot
III it's a ram going from Bologna with
III this is strange it should be a good
Ben Oni III I probably will be some kind
of tempo up if he goes a for now and now
and a five why not
I wonder I really have no idea in urban
or near sir not my account of territory
b5 Teague's and I Teague's stead a move
I can also just go nite your fire
probably what may be irritating on the
King side the idea is actually after if
I get an H for antique then my night
only five is more secure as f4 can be
answered with 95 there no H pawns it's
not a completely out wacky idea so let's
a castle its age for I will take on g3
and then I have G 449 as h three is not
working that was my idea at least maybe
it's not really important because of
this yes and what I didn't even consider
that move wow just wow okay
taking on f2 it's also interesting book
takes Knight g4 with Bishop d4 and queen
age 40 and so on TX on f 2 94 look f7
looks completely completely wild
check okay I'm taking it it was a thing
I feel actually I wanted to check the
other one yeah so I got irritated by a
message that I got okay empty I'm going
here yeah we gave seven huh yes I keokuk
f7 I also he has some group tricks g7
check then I can I can check on default
though first and then clean edge for
this is a completely insane position
probably not working but it's cool this
one really i thought we should be four
would be good here I can we can baby
chick with the ruckus simply
Wow check I can take with the rook and
now when I look is hanging there are
some kind of Queen age for your
threatening Queen you one but it is not
not that dangerous Queen age 498 hmm
that's not going to work how unfortunate
hmm I don't know what 40 wacky game I
usually had some positional play against
which was it probably better better
suited he's handling this wacky stuff
pretty well it seems or on or the other
way around or whatever I'm playing a bad
name okay normal stuff won't help anyway
98 now i'm chatting and going for 95 and
maybe i can get annoyed each two or
something crazy I'm lost here of course
subjectively but and anyway this one ok
so it's night H to move or is this
completely bad time morning
night each we can take on e5 with the
Queen this is a problem one of the
problems
I don't know 30 seconds Knight f6 is
probably just winning home check
it's got two minutes something I bishop
h6 just wins the Queen amongst others
hey Jack okay I'll find one of the winds
it wasn't the cleanest one but probably
winning as well I can't even take aid I
have no check yeah I have no check check
and made only seven checkmate yeah okay
that was entirely wild and it was
totally crazy to take on d6 here what a
move yeah Jim it is a central Palm may
be this good maybe it's good yeah okay
well here this is probably far taking it
too far chat chick yeah oops he took it
and he I'm really in a bad shape he can
take and check I mean I saw that this is
not working we need for birds I mean I
have no moves really this is hanging and
what exactly am i doing him no data that
was that was strong 96 I probably have
to do this and play this position and I
mean this is this is a very weird thing
yeah but he has got a good center maybe
I'm I really have to do 95 here I mean
this is definitely okay it's not bad but
not what I wanted to do it I didn't
really think of night takes t6 I just
thought okay he will take here and then
I go 95 it didn't that was a funny game
okay well thanks for watching